filet
à Ajay
fais-le
Est arrivé
Que
Faisons ce qui est beau ou
Ou nous sommes à nouveau la sorcière du vent chaque jour
venir d'ici à là
Ce
Que nous est-il arrivé pendant la tournée ?
tout à fait possible, où habites-tu
À Madhumey pour les installations de plage cachées
votre enfant et quelques enfants
une séquence normale comme le rouge
alors fais ton travail
Si ce n’est pas moins que n’importe qui, alors comme les autres enfants.
ce qui est toujours
à Ajay
Maintenant, certaines personnes n'y croient pas, mais
miracles dans la vie oui oui oui
oui maman disait
C'est ton destin d'acheter
Allez, écris quelque chose Ram Lahar
La messagerie vocale, je ne sais pas, a cliqué, c'est tout
Qui l’a écrit et pourquoi a-t-il été écrit ?
va me dire la métaphore de
tu m'as l'air très bien mec combien
rien ne peut tuer
à Ajay
fais-le
Ce que ma mère disait, Meena Zindagi
L'estomac devrait être comme Golgappa. Allez étudier.
je n'en ai pas envie
où nous savons
les histoires sont
important dans l'histoire
Rock On
[Appréciation]
filet